meanwhile boston hearing it
a bit from their fans this is the second
game of a seven game home stand as we
mentioned
monday night was the first time they had
the fans back 2800
this is a team that has just been
puzzling all season
at 23 and 24.
that's northeast fans though for you
mike they get back for the second game
their team has a little bit of a bad
stretch
and they are booing already i love it
that's what you love about northeast
fans
gotcha steps back luka doncic 18 points
three assists the lead back up to 19.
now four for 22 from long distance
as we approach two minutes remaining
dochich another step back
puts it in luka doncic lighting it up
here in the second quarter
a 22 point lead he's got 21.
[Applause]
tatum is on dotch with two all-stars two
of the brightest young stars in the nba
gotcha another step back three that's
good luca doncic on fire here in the
second quarter
24 points for the half halftime coming
up
including james harden and the nets
facing the rockets and highlights
from around the league on a busy
wednesday night luka doncic he's been
busy here in the first half
taking apart the boston celtics with 24
as the mavericks lead it 64-45 after two
at the td garden